oh look more things you didn't know
about breath of the wild I don't know
how we keep doing this if you continue
to follow this series though hit that
like button and let us know that you
want us to keep making these for you
alright let's go
some players may have come across this
weird thing in the Hebrew mountain range
sometimes you'll just get a random korok
literally for free
over the years this has happened to many
players and has gone on unexplained but
player Swifty has cracked the case a
while ago in this area there's a korok
that requires you to push a snowball
down this hill well in some instances
when you're moving closer to load the
Snowballs in then away from the
Snowballs moving farther away causes the
game engine to create less polygons in
the area and in turn deforms the ground
underneath the snowball into a downhill
slope automatically dropping the
snowball down the hill right into the
goal you can see it happen from this
shot here if you ever thought it was the
wind or a completely random glitch well
here you go mystery solved
another mystery players have run into is
a strange skewing of NPCs sometimes
completely sideways or underground these
cases started happening in 2019.
coincidentally right after the VR labo
update the 1.6 final patch that breath
of the wild ever saw on the switch the
Wii U version never got this while we
still don't know what's specifically in
the update causes the glitch to occur
thousands of players around the world
since then have been running into these
tilting Oddities did you know that any
of these types of Lookout Towers can be
cut down from below helps out in taking
out these annoying snipers
I have to add an addendum to the last
episode where I showed Lionel and moblin
warning horns were an idea that breath
of the wild developers scrapped and
never made it into the base game but
these are only partially true moblin
warning horns are a real thing and they
were fully modeled and ready to go not
only that they were fully ready and
animated with moblins on watchtowers
while this is only viewable from mods
the horn and the animation here is made
by Nintendo from breath of the wild
source code we just never got to see
these moblins on watchtowers and on top
of that we recently learned that Lionel
horns were indeed never developed for
breath of the wild but were finally
completed and used by the new enemy in
tears of the Kingdom called boss
bakoblins do you also know exactly how
warning horns work sometimes you'll see
them use it once or twice other times
they seem to use it over and over they
do this because they're programmed to
call the enemy Camp's attention until
most of them see you if most of the
camps still can't get a visual on you
they'll just keep blowing that horn
even tide Island as most players guessed
is Loosely based on the game Link's
Awakening especially with most players
taking a raft over here but the
developers put a tiny detail into the
weather specifically here most normal
areas of Hyrule have a percentage chance
of different Dynamic weather systems
such as clear sky cloudy rainy heavy
rain thunder thunderstorms snow rain
with clear sky Etc but even tide has its
own special weather system it's either
always clear skies or specifically from
5 PM to 9pm it will always shift to a
thunderstorm besides the gameplay
implications of making it a challenge
for players this may be a reference to
Link's awakening's very first
thunderstorm that washes link ashore
Coho land Island there's also a specific
area right here in the East akala plains
that spawns a stall Knox and in this
small circle around it it will
thunderstorm 24 7 no matter what getting
struck by lightning will light objects
around link on fire but did you also
notice that your core temperature goes
up to the max for a split second on the
same topic of electricity any number of
things can deflect octa-rock shots
hitting them Master Sword beams pairing
blocking Etc but did you also know that
you can deflect it with shock conduction
also know that you could block a
guardian's laser with a wind Cleavers
air slash yes
most of the time when you're cutting
grass you'll get lizards or crickets
that pop out for you to catch but these
areas of grass are categorized by a
region and different regions have
different drop tables for materials such
as hot footed frogs in the Gerudo region
highly in rice in the forearm region to
ban the wheat in the tabantha region and
the weirdest one the Elden region which
in its limited patches of grass have a
10 chance to drop a piece of Amber ore
instead breath of the Wild's map is
absolutely littered with hundreds of
locations most which reference out
characters or places of past Zelda games
some are easier to point out than others
so for a couple episodes we'll start
listing some references Nintendo has
made tarm point is a reference to the
tarm ruins in Oracle of Seasons where a
golden Lionel is placed as well the Lost
Woods are pretty straightforward medo
and zarya are from the Kokiri Forest in
Ocarina of Time but the korok references
push out a little bit farther mccar Elma
and urge are all koroks from the Wind
Waker and to the southeast you have
location such as the minishi woods and
Pico Pond both names are the Minish race
Crandall Hills which is a reference to
mount kernel in the Minish Cap and droby
plain which is a reference to Trilby
Highlands funny how the wording of
mountains to Hills and Highlands to
Plains is changed in reference to Link's
size perspective in his Minish form this
of course makes sense because
fujibayashi planned to have a form of
diminished NPCs in the game but from a
gameplay standpoint he was unfortunately
not able to make this work from the only
screenshot Nintendo gave us there's
theories that this may be here at the
minishi woods with the Lost Woods fog in
the background talking about locations
through development location names were
subject to change for various reasons
and some of them had placeholder names
you can see some of these strange names
of locations through the breath of the
wild object map with notable ones like
tie flow ruins previously called dark
wood Santa din Park ruins called Brave
Horse Park Lane Roux Promenade called
spider nest Mountain which in the
creating a champion book is corroborated
tanagar can Union called Oblivion Valley
lurlin Village called Southern Village
and Terry Town listed as Yumi Village
what is you me though well it was found
a while ago that Nintendo had a system
for creating hylians and Chica called
Yumi that seemed to be a more advanced
version of the Mii Creator while we
don't exactly know what the system looks
like this supports the theory that
Nintendo used this internal system to
help easily create its 400 plus NPCs to
dot the land of Hyrule on the night
Claymore there's highly in text on there
that's pretty hard to make out when
translated it says Hyrule Kingdom power
wisdom courage did you know that the
master sword's ability to power up near
Guardians is not directly tied to link
you can consider the sword I guess to be
sort of sentient able to detect
Guardians on its own in its vicinity on
the ground or even in enemy hands
[Music]
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time just let us know in the
comments below of course we'll keep
going with this series until tears of
the Kingdom where we'll continue on with
the series over there but for everything
else gaming you know where to go right
here on Gamespot
[Music]